[Musica]
[Applauso]
vedere l'invisibile
misurare vedere osservare
questi qua sono dei termini che
solitamente associamo alla scienza e qui
vediamo un eccellente personaggio che
noi all'università di padova
conosciamo molto bene
galileo galilei quindi come non portare
la sua presenza in questa presentazione
galileo ha detto una frase ha detto che
non basta guardare ma occorre guardare
con occhi che vogliono vedere e che
vogliono credere quello che stanno
vedendo
oggi parleremo di una tecnologia che ci
consente di vedere vedere anche
divisibile vedere cose che accadono sul
nostro pianeta
ma qui abbiamo un altro personaggio un
nostro contemporaneo
lui si chiama daniel cane man e premio
nobel per l'economia però è psicologo e
lui studia e irrazionalità dei processi
decisionali umani e abbiamo appena
sentito un toc sull'a30 grazio nalità
dei processi decisionali umani
osservare la superficie della terra
perché è così importante vedere le cose
prendiamo una frase da questo film c'è
una frase lapidaria
che dice noi desideriamo quello che
vediamo e questo questa frase veniva
detta per spiegare un comportamento di
una persona ha detto questa persona si
comporta in un certo modo perché
desidera ma desidera qualcosa che ha
visto
se noi non vediamo le cose non possiamo
fare nulla per risolverla quindi noi
potremmo anche allargare questo concetto
e potremmo dire non solo dobbiamo vedere
le cose dobbiamo rendercene conto perché
altrimenti non faremo mai nulla per
risolverlo saremo completamente in balia
degli eventi
ma osservare le cose non basta
noi abbiamo dei buyers ovverosia i
nostri sensi ci ingannano quindi noi
possiamo anche vedere le cose quindi
possiamo avere degli strumenti che fanno
delle foto a degli oggetti però
osservando le potremo trarre conclusioni
completamente sbagliata
questa è la classica illusione ottica
e il quadrato al quadrato b sembrano
diversi c'è qualcuno che li vede con lo
stesso colore
in verità il quadrato è inquadrato b
sembrano diversi ma sono esattamente
identici bene qualcuno può dirmi sono
identici ma come fare a crederci
bene la scienza ci dà degli strumenti
per analizzare le cose in modo oggettivo
e questo è molto importante proprio per
portare più razionalità dei nostri e le
nostre decisioni
e questo potete farlo anche voi se
andate su un browser andate su un sito
dove c'è quest'immagine fate tasto
destro sul computer ci sono degli
strumenti e c'è uno strumento che
consente di analizzare il colore di ogni
singolo pixel del vostro schermo
queste analisi del colore è proprio
quello che viene fatto in questa
tecnologia che si chiama telerilevamento
ovverosia rilevamento di immagini
e se noi facciamo questa operazione qua
vedremo che la il quadrato al quadrato
di hanno esattamente la stessa il suo
stesso colore
la stessa firma spettrale firma
spettrale è un termine più complicato
più tecnico
semplicemente per descrivere quanto
rosso quanto verde quanto blu è composto
il quadrato a il quadrato b e se lo fate
vedrete che sono esattamente identici
111 112 112 sia il quadrato anche il
quadrato di
quindi questa tecnologia ci ha dato
l'obiettività una misura
però la scacchiera è molto semplice
noi vogliamo analizzare
qualcosa di molto più complesso
il nostro bellissimo pianeta azzurro un
pianeta che ormai abitato da 8 miliardi
di persone quasi queste persone vogliono
stare bene vogliono
vogliono muoversi con la macchina
vogliono mangiare bene questo però un
impatto lo studiamo noi anche al tesa
l'impatto che all'essere umano sul
pianeta ma ne sentite parlare in
televisione ogni giorno
quindi osservare dall'alto praticamente
esattamente il contrario che faceva
galileo perché galileo guardava gli
astri noi invece da dallo spazio
guardiamo la superficie terrestre
guardare dall'alto è una tecnologia
molto utile e lo sapevo lo si sapeva già
da tempo ma noi abbiamo adesso degli
strumenti ben più sofisticati di questi
simpatici piccioni
possiamo utilizzare i satelliti
i satelliti orbitano intorno alla terra
e possono essere equipaggiati di
tantissimi sensori sensori che vedono
non solo quello che vediamo con gli
occhi ma anche l'invisibile voi sapete
l'arcobaleno l'avete visto tutti sapete
forse alcuni di voi sanno che dopo il
rosso cioè l'infrarosso voi noi non lo
vediamo ma c'è prima del blu cell
ultravioletto non lo vediamo ma ha un
effetto
questo è un oggetto orbitante molto
famoso la stazione spaziale
internazionale
anche questa equipaggiata con tante
tanti sensori che fanno delle foto ed è
un bellissimo esempio di quello che fa
che può fare l'essere umano quando
collabora invece che mettersi in trincea
e spararsi addosso
questo oggetto fa 15 volte e mezzo il
giro del pianeta ogni 24 ore
perché perché viaggia 27 mila chilometri
all'ora a 400 chilometri di quota quindi
immaginate quanta superficie riesce a
fotografare e quante cose riesce a
vedere
non è l'unico ce ne sono tantissimi i
satelliti non tutti fanno queste cose
qui ma molti osservano la superficie
terrestre
vi sentite osservati
ma noi andiamo osservare qualcosa di non
sempre piacevole cioè l'impatto che
l'essere umano sul pianeta queste sono
delle immagini forse le avete già
sentite la foresta amazzonica che c'è
una trasformazione di uso del suolo
insomma in terreno agricolo
c'è anche l'utilizzo dell'acqua per
l'udeur per l'agricoltura le persone
devono mangiare però questo è un effetto
ha un impatto
poterlo vedere in modo così chiaro aiuta
a prendere coscienza consapevolezza di
quello che stiamo facendo e decidere se
ci va bene o cio non ci va bene
possiamo vedere anche dei fenomeni meno
preoccupanti come le sa bene sarà che
vengono spostate da un continente
all'altro
a volte quando vengono prese da alcune
correnti
vedere l'invisibile però consente di
spingere verso delle decisioni che
altrimenti non prenderemo mai
questo qua è un esempio di portare
qualcosa di completamente invisibile che
è lo strato dell'ozono
in un'immagine a colori ma colori con
dietro delle misure scientifica quindi
non colori a caso e questo è molto
importante e qui possiamo vedere una
nota per fortuna positiva che questo
quando è stata presa e la consapevolezza
di questo problema qua sono state fatte
delle politiche e questi hanno
funzionato adesso sembra che lo strato
dell'ozono se sia ricostituendo ma
quanti di voi vedono l'ozono
quante volte usciamo e diciamo oggi
l'ozono mi sembra un po sottile no ci
vogliono degli strumenti che portano
l'invisibile a vedere a farci vedere
cosa come
forse alcuni di voi conoscono questa
piazza una piazza bastanza nota al prato
della valle
se lo vediamo con i colori normali
possiamo apprezzare si molte cose ma se
andiamo all'infrarosso notiamo una cosa
molto interessante perché la vegetazione
riflette tantissimo l'infrarosso mentre
l'acqua l'assorbe qui noi vediamo
chiaramente
vediamo chiaramente il canale intorno al
prato della valle rispetto alla
vegetazione
questo ci permette anche di vedere il
verde urbano e di capire quanto verde
urbano cioè in una città e questo
succede molto chiaramente proprio perché
le piante hanno una composizione chimica
della foglia tale che riflette l'inter
nell'infrarosso
questo ci consente di fare anche
un'altra cosa capire lo stato di salute
delle piante perché quando la pianta è
malata diciamo cambia composizione
chimica e non riflette più bene
l'infrarosso quindi noi vedremmo un
immagine come quella a destra invece che
bianco la vedremo grigia appassita
questo interessante però noi dicevamo
noi vogliamo vedere cosa succede nel
mondo allora noi possiamo usare queste
tecnologie per vedere addirittura cosa
succede sull'intero continente durante
l'arco delle stagioni e vedere proprio
come respira anche il continente perché
la vegetazione lo sappiamo respiro
questo è collegato anche a tante cose
non è soltanto la presenza un assenza di
vegetazione noi sappiamo ad esempio che
la desertificazione ha un impatto
fortissimo sulla popolo sulle
popolazioni
perché porta fame povertà guerre e
migrazioni
quindi capire effettivamente cosa
succede è importante è che parchi per
capire dove c'è scritto che stiamo
andando per capire quale può essere il
nostro futuro
ossigeno
beh l'ossigeno certamente quanto
respiriamo respiriamo un'aria che
potrebbe anche non essere sempre pulita
però una cosa è uscire e di reva mi
sembra un pochino che oggi se un po
inquinata ma una cosa è un'altra cosa è
vedere l'impatto cioè la qualità
dell'aria nelle nostre città e ci
preoccupa un po almeno a me e vedere
anche come questo cambia durante durante
l'anno quindi quanti sono i momenti
peggiori per respirare quelli con meno
ossigeno possiamo dire
però conoscere queste cose qua ci aiuta
perché non bisogna chiudere gli occhi
bisogna capire per poter prendere
consapevolezza è il primo passo la
consapevolezza per poi fare delle azioni
per mitigare per aiutare per risolverlo
quindi vorrei concludere immaginandomi
di parlare con le due persone
dell'inizio noi possiamo dire a galileo
guarda galileo è vero non basta guardare
ma bisogna vedere e noi adesso vediamo
tantissimo perché vi assicuro che ci
arrivano talmente tanti dati che non
riusciamo neanche ad elaborarli perché
abbiamo tantissimi sensori che
analizzano tutto il nostro pianeta ogni
giorno
se invece pensiamo di parlare con daniel
potremmo dire caro dani hai ragione tu
hai studiato e hai visto che i processi
decisionali umani sono spesso
irrazionale ma noi abbiamo la scienza
possiamo correggere questi processi
decisionali e quindi migliorare il
nostro mondo quindi di strumenti ce li
abbiamo
i dati abbiamo visto ce ne sono
tantissimi anche quello che non era
visibile adesso è diventato visibile
non abbiamo più del degli alibi non
possiamo fare come i bambini e dire non
avevo visto non lo sapevo
lo sappiamo perché adesso vediamo quasi
tutto possiamo dire ma c'è una cosa che
questi strumenti
non ci potranno mai dare che è il cuore
e la volontà di usarli intelligentemente
per il beneficio di tutti
[Applauso]